[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend es
kommt ja selten genug vor dass man hier
an dieser Stelle mit einer guten
Nachricht beginnen kann auf dem
weltnaturgipfel in Montreal hat es eine
Einigung gegeben mit einer großen
Mehrheit der Staaten wurde ein globales
Abkommen zum Artenschutz verabschiedet
auch wenn da viel erstmal nur auf dem
Papier steht selbst einige
Umweltschutzorganisationen bewerten das
als einen Erfolg der gerade noch
rechtzeitig kommt wenn es gelingen soll
Tiere und Pflanzen im Wasser und an Land
künftig besser zu schützen und das
Artensterben aufzuhalten Andreas
berichtet
tief hinein in den Dschungel von Borneo
fahren drei Kisten Hoffnung sie fahren
14 Stunden lang sie fahren soweit weg
wie möglich vom größten vom
gefährlichsten Feind aller Tiere dem
Menschen in den Kisten harren drei
Hoffnungsträger aus drei ganz besondere
ihrer Art Lima ist der 498 Orang-Utan
den die Artenschützer aus wildern
Gonzales ist der 499 und Ben 12 Jahre
alt neugierig und gelierig der 500ste
ist natürlich ein riesen Sieg für den
Atemschutz weil 500 € Orang-Utans in der
Freiheit heißt natürlich
eine realistische Chance dass die Art
auch erhalten werden kann zumindest
aufbauen ja und ähm großer Hoffnung für
die Zukunft und auch gerade in düsteren
Zeiten wo wir natürlich viele Arten
verlieren weltweit ist das schon in Sieg
es gibt mehr Niederlagen als Siege im
Kampf gegen das Artensterben auch die
Verhandlungen in Montreal sehen
zwischendurch wie ein weiteres scheitern
aus aber als vergangenen Nacht der
hammerfeld
die Überraschung Jubel die
Staatengemeinschaft die Menschheit setzt
sich ein beachtliches Ziel bis 2030
sollen mindestens 30% aller Land und
Meeresflächen unter Schutz stehen der
Einsatz von Pestiziden soll um die
Hälfte reduziert werden 20 Milliarden
Euro sagen die Industriestaaten zu so
wollen die reicheren Länder wie
Deutschland die besonders viel Natur
verbraucht haben den ärmeren Ländern von
denen viele noch besonders viel Natur
haben helfen im Interesse von allen wenn
so viele Arten aussterben dann geraten
die Ökosysteme aus dem Takt und Sie
verlieren ihre Funktionen die für uns
überlebenswichtig sind
Umweltschützer loben die Einigung die
Theorie von Montreal sind aber skeptisch
über die Praxis
Wildtierhandel Korruption gebrochene
Politiker versprechen es gibt viele
Gründe aus denen Arten sterben die
menschliche Gier die menschlichen Gründe
sterben nicht aus also im Endeffekt ist
es zweitrangig was in Montreal passiert
im Endeffekt on the ground also vor Ort
zählt der Schutz nur der Mensch kann das
Tier vor dem Menschen schützen ob sich
was ändert für bedrohte Arten hängt
davon ab ob die Menschheit sich ändert
andreas kühnerst hat diesen Gipfel für
uns in Montreal beobachtet Andreas zur
Wahrheit dieses Gipfels gehört es ja
auch dass afrikanische Länder teils
dagegen waren oder auch aus Brasilien
gab es Kritik inwiefern kann sich das
negativ auswirken denn gezwungen
mitzumachen wird ja keiner
ja das ist wirklich einer der ganz
großen Minuspunkte hier im Montreal das
gerade einige der artenreichsten
afrikanischen Staaten hier unglücklich
nach Hause fahren der Kongo ist sogar
das einzige Land das gegen das Abkommen
gestimmt hat Kamerun und Uganda haben
von einem erzwungenen Abkommen
gesprochen und sie alle sagen das Geld
das hier locker gemacht wurde in
Montreal reicht bei weitem nicht aus die
Ziele die hier beschlossen wurden sind
zu schwammig und es gibt zu wenig
Handhabe um sie durchzusetzen und es
gibt nicht wenige NGOs nicht weniger
Umweltschützer die sagen ja sie haben
Recht aber trotzdem gibt es ja auch viel
positive Resonanz auf dieses Abkommen
woran liegt denn dann die eigentliche
Bedeutung
darin dass es jetzt überhaupt erstmal
einen Plan gibt Montreal war für dieses
Jahrzehnt die letzte Chance dass ich die
Weltgemeinschaft dass ich die
Staatengemeinschaft überhaupt mal
gemeinsam auf einen Plan gegen das
Artensterben einigt und da ist dann
dieses Ziel 30 Prozent des Planeten
unter Schutz zu stellen wirklich
beachtlich wird wirklich ambitioniert
und das ist die Leistung von Montreal
das im Prinzip alle Länder erkannt haben
kleine Schritte kleine Ziele reichen
jetzt nicht mehr Montreal hat vielleicht
noch nicht die nötigen Mittel gebracht
aber zum ersten Mal an gemeinsamen
Willen danke schön für die Einordnung
nach Montreal Andreas
auf den Schlachtfeldern der Ukraine wird
der Welt vor Augen geführt dass die
russische Armee nicht so schlagkräftig
ist wie sie vor diesem Angriffskrieg
glauben machte sich selbst und andere
man kann nur hoffen dass Putin und
seinen generellen derzeit nicht nach
weiteren Kriegsgebieten in der
Nachbarschaft zumute ist etwa nach einem
Angriff auf das Baltikum andernfalls
müsste dort ab Januar eine schnelle
Nato-Truppe unter deutscher Führung
Eingreifen die mit ersatzpanzern aus den
70er Jahren angereist kommt das ist
unterm Strich die peinliche Erkenntnis
dieses Wochenende ist nach dem
öffentlich wurde dass die neuen Puma
Panzer der Bundeswehr zwar theoretisch
hoch modern sind praktisch aber nicht
einsatzfähig das zieht nun Kreise
berichtet Andreas Hoppe
Hightech aus Stahl Computer auf Ketten
kein Superlativ war dem Militär und den
Herstellern zu groß um den
Schützenpanzer Puma bei seiner in
Dienststellung zu Preisen
2015 wurden die ersten der Bundeswehr
übergeben seitdem ist allerdings wenig
zu spüren vom hightech-wunder auf Ketten
Pannen über Pannen Feuchtigkeit führte
mutmaßlich zu Software Fehlern dadurch
streikte dann die Technik Einsatz aus
für den Super Puma es waren oftmals
technische Ausfälle und wenn ich
sozusagen wie im Auto der Strom aus geht
dann können sie nicht gut bremsen haben
sie kein Bremskraftverstärker da kriegen
sie die Heckklappe nicht mehr auf und
und und und ist ja alles heute mit
Elektronik versehen das waren die
bekannten Schwierigkeiten der
Schützenpanzer also ein Mängelexemplar
im Juli 2020 stellt die Bundeswehr
dieses Attest den Puma erstmals auch
schriftlich aus der neue Schützenpanzer
habe erhebliche Mängel sei nicht
einsatzfähig und damit nicht
kriegstauglich so ein interner Bericht
schnellstens sollte Abhilfe geschafft
werden doch die Verteidigungsministerin
stellt jetzt im April fest die
Bundeswehr habe nur auf dem Papier 350
Puma Panzer einsatzbereit sein lediglich
150 dabei bräuchte man allein für alle
Bündnisverpflichtungen innerhalb der
NATO 266 Stück
das die pomas jetzt in reinen ausfallen
bei Manövern ist sehr bedenklich und
zeigt dass wir ganz dringend und
überfälligerweise eine andere Art der
materialmanagements und auch der
Beschaffung bei der Bundeswehr brauchen
eine für heute geplante
Vertragsunterzeichnung für weitere puma
wurde auf Eis gelegt 14 Tage hat die
Industrie jetzt Zeit die Probleme in den
Griff zu kriegen die linke Opposition
fordert Schadensersatz wenn man
Milliarden ausgibt und dann letztlich 6
Milliarden Schrott erhält dann muss die
Verteidigungsministerin die Frage des
Regresses stellen die deutsche
Rüstungsindustrie ist offensichtlich
nicht in der Lage derartige Dinge zu
produzieren um jetzt die Natur
Verpflichtungen zu erfüllen holt die
Bundeswehr einen alten bewährten
Veteranen aus den Depots den Marder
ebenfalls Schützenpanzer 1969
vorgestellt gegen die ersten Exemplare
ein 71 an die Bundeswehr 50 Jahre alter
Marder Stadt modernster Puma ist vorerst
die Lösung da ist keine Veränderung die
Fähigkeit ist die gleiche mit dem Maler
wie mit einem Puma die CDU waren der
Auswahl des Puma dürfe nicht dazu führen
dass Panzerlieferungen an die Ukraine
damit völlig ausgeschlossen sind die
modernen Bestände des Marders die
innerhalb der Bundeswehr sind können
jetzt als Ersatz für die Puma verwendet
werden aber sie sollten nicht als
Entschuldigung dafür gelten dass die
Industrie nicht mögliche Lieferung an
die Ukraine vorbereiten darf das
hightech-wunder auf Ketten sein Ausfall
für die NATO-Mission ist peinlich für
Deutschland ob der Puma überhaupt eine
Zukunft in der Bundeswehr hat ist heute
fraglicher denn je
und die bundesverteidigungsministerin
ist derzeit auf einem vorweihnachtlichen
Truppenbesuch bei deutschen Soldaten in
der Slowakei guten Abend Frau lambrecht
schönen guten Abend Frau Lanka was
machen wir denn jetzt mit diesem Pumas
einstampfen das ganze Projekt der
Industrie die Mangelware zurückgeben und
was anderes kaufen was praxisstauglich
ist
also ich erwarte jetzt dass die Pumas
die fehlerhaft sind die jetzt
festgestellt wurden schnellstmöglich
schnellstmöglich von der Industrie
instand gesetzt werden das ist der erste
Schritt das hilft uns aber dauerhaft
nicht weiter sondern ich erwarte eine
Perspektive die wir verlässlich mit
diesen Pumas rechnen können wie man also
verlässlich diese Fehler beheben kann
wir können uns nicht immer von einer
Instandsetzung zur anderen Handeln zu
wir brauchen verlässliche Lösungen oder
die Entscheidung nicht mehr länger auf
den Puma zu setzen das ist eine
Entscheidung die er zum Beispiel die
holländerzeit als man auch merkte welche
Probleme ist mit diesem Projekt gehabt
diese Mängel sind ja alle nicht neu wir
hatten schon 2015 Probleme mit dem Puma
da kam irgendwie Wasser ins Kanonenrohr
und ähnliches also da sind die Holländer
ja zum Beispiel ausgestiegen und haben
lieber was praktisches und nicht ganz so
hochgerüstetes in Schweden gekauft der
das nicht vielleicht für uns auch eine
Lösung
wir haben in den letzten Jahren und bei
verschiedenen Übungen eigentlich
vielversprechende Ergebnisse erzielt mit
dem Puma von daher glaube ich ist es
doch noch mal die Mühe wert mit der
Industrie zu beraten ob es denn in
irgendeiner Weise Verlässlichkeit geben
kann das muss aber sehr zügig gehen denn
wir haben Verpflichtungen und die wollen
wir auch innerhalb der NATO einhalten
und deswegen ist jetzt aktuell die
Forderung an die Industrie erstens
instandsetzen dieser Pumas die jetzt
gerade aufgefallen sind und darüber
hinaus uns ein Konzept vorzulegen aber
das muss sehr schnell gehen und wenn es
nicht funktioniert wenn es nicht möglich
ist dann müssen tatsächlich andere
Entscheidungen nehmen ganz kurz gefragt
setzen sie da eine Frist dass sie sagen
bis dahin will ich ein Ergebnis sehen
oder wir schwenken um
ja das wird keineswegs mehr Monate
dauern können die Instandsetzung die
muss sehr schnell gehen da erwarte ich
also auch keine keine Zusagen innerhalb
vieler Wochen sondern innerhalb weniger
und bei der Verlässlichkeit ja da
erwarte ich tatsächlich dass wir in
wenigen Wochen auch uns dann auf eine
Lösung verständigen können denn
ansonsten kann ich die Verantwortung
nicht übernehmen wir müssten ansonsten
investieren in eine Nachrüstung diese
Verträge werden wir nicht unterschreiben
und auch ein zweites los sprich weitere
Bestellungen wird es nicht geben
deswegen Schnelligkeit ist jetzt gefragt
die Industrie ist in der Pflicht und
diesen Weg werden wir gemeinsam gehen
oder dann ihn eben auch abbrechen wenn
es sein muss Schnelligkeit bräuchte die
Bundeswehr ja auch bei anderen
Beschaffungen also Munition zum Beispiel
jetzt haben wir seit 10 Monaten diesen
Angriffskrieg aber nicht die
entsprechenden Geschosse für Geparden
oder Panzerhaubitzen besorgt und stehen
da jetzt in der Warteschleife warum
dauert das denn bei Ihnen im Haus so
lange
den Gepard den hatten wir schon längst
ausgepreist den gibt es den gab es bei
der Bundeswehr gar nicht mehr und zwar
schon sehr lange und alles was wir an
Munition haben hatten wir an die Ukraine
geliefert deswegen ist das wirklich eine
Situation die die erwartet dass wir
jetzt eine neue Produktionsstätte
auflegen also nicht wir sondern die
Industrie und da kommt Bewegung rein das
auch dieses System wieder entsprechend
bestückt werden kann aber ansonsten sind
wir unter Hochdruck daran Munition zu
beschaffen mit allen Möglichkeiten die
sich uns bietet jetzt ist endlich auch
das Geld da das heißt die
Haushaltsmittel stehen zur Verfügung und
deswegen kann auch beschafft werden aber
es ist tatsächlich so ja wir haben auch
in den letzten Monaten sehr viel
abgegeben an die Ukraine weil wir sie in
ihrem mutigen Kampf in diesem brutalen
Angriffskrieg unterstützt haben dann
sieht man gerade wenn man Blick in die
Ukraine auch mit Videos dort von den von
den Kriegsszenarien wie dringend
schützen Panzer gebraucht werden und
auch welche die nicht nur antik sind wir
unsere Marder dann irgendwann wenn da
Infanterie quasi ungeschützt übers Feld
läuft dann hatte die Ukraine ja die
Hoffnung von uns irgendwann auch Marder
zu bekommen kann sie die Hoffnung jetzt
begraben weil die Bundeswehr die die
noch bei der Industrie stehen jetzt für
sich selber braucht
also aus der Bundeswehr werden wir ganz
bestimmt keine Mader abgehen aus der
Industrie sieht man gerade jetzt wieder
in der in dieser Situation und wir
helfen mit dass die Ukraine Panzer
geliefert bekommt ich bin hier gerade in
der Slowakei und von hier wurden werden
Panzer abgegeben 30 noch sowjetischer
Bauart und wir helfen wiederum dass dann
in der Slowakei diese Lücken geschlossen
werden der sogenannte Ringtausch es ist
wichtig dass es schnell geht das schnell
geliefert werden kann aber was die
Ukraine ganz dringend braucht ist
Luftverteidigung sie müssen sich gegen
diesen Raketen gegen diesen Drohnen
Terror verteidigen könnte deswegen ist
beispielsweise unser System ihres Tee so
wichtig und das im nächsten Jahr auch
wenn die Industrie dann liefert auch
weitere Systeme kommen dass unser
gepaart schützen kann die kritische
Infrastruktur und Luftverteidigung
Atelier das ist wichtig und die Ukraine
zu unterstützen in der
Durchhaltefähigkeit und auch deshalb bin
ich hier in der Slowakei wir haben hier
einen instandsetzungshub jetzt hier
einrichten können
etwas schneller unsere Waffensysteme die
wir in die Ukraine geliefert haben auch
wieder reparieren zu können wenn es denn
notwendig ist und natürlich bei dem
Einsatz bei dem Gebrauch ist es
notwendig und es ist schnell gelungen
damit die Wege kurz sind die Ukraine so
zu unterstützen dadurch dass schnell
entstand gesetzt werden kann und dann
weiter gekämpft werden kann voll lange
recht danke für das Gespräch
ich danke Ihnen
das Interview haben wir vor einer Stunde
geführt und mit der aktuellen Lage der
Ukraine geht es jetzt bei dir weiter
Hans ja auch heute wurde die Hauptstadt
Kiew wieder von Russland aus der Luft
angegriffen mit Drohnen iranischer
Bauart nach ukrainischen Angaben habe
die Luftabwehr nicht alle Drohnen über
Kiew abfangen können Teile der
Energieversorgung wurden zerstört und
den einigen Stadtteilen wurde der Strom
abgeschaltet im Umland wurden zu dem
Wohnhäuser getroffen und zwei Zivilisten
verletzt
nur wenige Stunden nach diesen massiven
Luftangriffen auf die Ukraine ist
russlands Präsident Putin nach Minsk
gereist das erste Mal seit drei Jahren
beim gemeinsamen Treffen betonte der
belarussische Präsident Lukaschenko das
sein Land die militärische
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland vertiefen
wollen russland hat heute taktische
Militärmanöver mit Belarus angekündigt
in der Ukraine befürchtet man weiter
einen Angriff russischer Truppen aus
Belarus
in Washington hat der
Untersuchungsausschuss zum Sturm auf das
Kapitol eine strafrechtliche Verfolgung
von Ex-Präsident Trump empfohlen der
Ausschuss wirft Trump unter anderem
Verschwörung zum Betrug an den USA und
Aufruhr vor diese Empfehlung des
Gremiums geht an das Justizministerium
das aber nicht daran gebunden ist der
Ausschuss untersuchte wie es am 6 Januar
2021 zum Sturm von radikalen Anhängern
Trumps auf den Sitz des US-Kongresses
kam als dort der Wahlsieg von Joe Biden
glaube ich werden sollte
rund 90 Jahre ist es her dass eine
Rabbinerfamilie vor dem nazior die
Nachfahren der posners besuchten nun
Deutschland und feiert mit
Bundespräsident Steinmeier das Licht der
fest hanuka im Schloss Bellevue
entzündete ein Enkel jeruda mannsbach
den Leuchter den die Familie ins heutige
Israel mitgenommen hatte
Steinmeier nannte ist ein Geschenk das
in Deutschland wieder jüdisches Leben
blüht und forderte die Menschen auf
gegen jede Form von Antisemitismus
Haltung zu zeigen
die niederländische Regierung hat sich
rund 150 Jahre nach dem Ende der
Sklaverei in den früheren Kolonien des
Landes für das geschehene Unrecht
entschuldigt Ministerpräsident mal
grütte sprach in einer
Regierungserklärung vor Vertretern von
Nachfahren für sklavter Menschen von
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
deren Folgen bis heute spürbar sein
außerdem kündigte er einen Fonds für
Initiativen an die sich mit dem Erbe der
Sklaverei befassen und Aufklärungsarbeit
leisten
als Robert Haarwerk nach Brüssel reiste
wird er schon geahnt haben dass das für
ihn keine allzu erfreuliche
Veranstaltung wird sondern ist aus Sicht
der Bundesregierung eher um
Schadensbegrenzung geht die Mehrheit der
anderen EU-Länder wollte unbedingt einen
europäischen gaspreisdeckel also eine
gemeinsame Obergrenze beim Gaseinkauf
Deutschland ist das skeptisch und
befürchtet ungewollte Nebenwirkungen
konnte sich mit den Bedenken aber nicht
durchsetzen ulfrella erklärt noch mal
kurz worum es geht
am Ende musste Robert Habeck seinen
Widerstand aufgeben denn die Mehrheit
der eu-energieminister will einen
gaspreisdeckel nach zehn Verhandlungen
lenkte der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister
ein um nicht überstimmt zu werden der
aktuelle EU-Ratsvorsitzende verkündet
einen Kompromiss
unsere Arbeit getan wir haben einen Deal
eine weitere unmögliche Aufgabe gelöst
Europa will einen Höchstpreis für
gasfest setzen den es zahlen will Grund
der Gaspreis erreicht in diesem Jahr
Spitzenwerte von mehr als 300 Euro pro
mega wattstunde aktuell liegt er bei
etwas über hundert Euro die
EU-Kommission hat sich nun auf einen
preisdeckel von 180 Euro geeinigt
die Sorge von Habeck sollte der
Weltmarktpreis höher liegen als 180 Euro
verkauften die Händler ihr Gas woanders
eine Skepsis dass wir mit einem
markteingriff
Nebeneffekte provozieren die wir nicht
publizieren wollten die ist geblieben
daraus kann ich kein Helm machen in
Ausnahmefällen dürfen die
EU-Mitgliedstaaten den gaspreisdeckel
außer Kraft setzen zum Beispiel wenn ein
Land nicht genügend Gas bekommt darauf
haben sie sich heute auch geeinigt für
Robert Habeck ein kleiner Triumph am
Ende eines langen harten Tages
fragen wir noch mal nach bei ulfräulein
Brüssel man hat den Andruck die
Bundesregierung verfolgte auch so ein
bisschen das Prinzip Hoffnung nämlich
dass der Deckel gar nicht greifen muss
also ich glaube der Eindruck ist absolut
Recht die Bundesregierung hat in den
monatelangen Verhandlungen alles
versucht um diesen gaspreisdeckel zu
verhindern weil sie ihn einfach für das
falsche Instrument hält aber am Ende hat
sie erkannt sie kommt immer mehr in eine
Minderheiten Position und wollte eben
verhindern dass sie bestimmt wird
insofern hat man dann jetzt in den
letzten Stunden und auch Tagen komplett
die Kraft darauf gesetzt die Ausnahme
Regeln die den gaspreisdeckel außer
Kraft setzen besonders hart und gut
auszufahren das glaubt habe ist ihm
jetzt einigermaßen gelungen insofern ist
etwas skeptisch aber nicht komplett
frustriert zurückgefahren das Problem
liegt darin dass die Befürworter des
graspreisdeckels erstens den Gast bei
Deckel sehr gut finden und zweitens
sagen die Ausnahme Regeln sind eine
Ausnahme Regeln und so wird es
wahrscheinlich im nächsten Jahr wenn man
wieder Gas einkaufen muss für den
nächsten Winter und jeder damit rechnet
dass die Gaspreise nach oben gehen und
Gas knapp ist dann wird es einen neuen
Streit um den gaspreisdeckel geben also
die unendliche Geschichte und diesen
Deckel hat nur weitere Wendungen
bekommen Dankeschön Ulf nach Brüssel und
viele Hintergrundinfos und auch
praktische Energiespartipps finden Sie
bei uns online auf ZDF heute und mit dem
energiethema-gesetz auch bei den noch
mal weiterheizen ja das schrittweise aus
der russischen Gaslieferungen nach
Deutschland hat die Frage der
Versorgungssicherheit neu gestellt und
auch den Energiemarkt verändert und da
bei der realer gab es heute ein
interessante Entscheidung ja und die
betrifft Juniper Deutschlands größter
aber eben auch Krisen geplagter
Gasversorger dessen Aktionäre haben
heute der Verstaatlichung zugestimmt mit
großer Mehrheit dass es keine besonders
große Überraschung ohne die Hilfe des
Staates hätte unerwohl kaum eine Chance
gehabt und Anlegern hätte vermutlich ein
total Verlust gedroht nun soll alles
ganz schnell gehen laut
Wirtschaftsministerium wird der Bund bei
Juniper wohl noch diese Woche einsteigen
eine teure Rettungsaktion 33 Milliarden
Euro pumpt der Staat in das Stimmen in
dem er neue Aktien kauft außerdem kommt
noch ein Kredit hinzu in Höhe von 18
Milliarden Euro die EU-Kommission muss
die staatlichen Beihilfen noch
genehmigen vermutlich wird sie grünes
Licht geben aber nur unter Auflagen in
Frage käme der Verkauf einzelner
Firmenteile bislang setzt das
Unternehmen auf Atomkraft Gas und Kohle
Technologien also die mittelfristig
Auslaufmodelle sein dürften June pavill
künftig stärker in umweltfreundlichen
Wasserstoff und erneuerbare Energien
investieren der gasimporteur wird sich
neu erfinden müssen für den Bund heißt
das vermutlich die Steuer Milliarden
bleiben noch bei Juniper geparkt denn
bis der Staat wenn überhaupt mit Gewinn
wieder aussteigen kann wird es wohl noch
Jahre dauern
vielen Dank
ein Regengebiet ist seit letzter Nacht
von Westen her über weite Teile
Deutschlands gezogen und hat auf
tiefgefrorenem Boden zu gefährlich im
Glatteis geführt auf spiegelglatten
Gehwegen und Straßen war es schwierig
voranzukommen es gab hunderte
Verkehrsunfälle auf der A27 bei Walsrode
in Niedersachsen kam ein Mensch ums
Leben
Züge der Deutschen Bahn durften wegen
Eisregens und Eisbildung vorübergehend
nur mit reduziertem Tempo fahren am
Flughäfen wie hier in Frankfurt kam es
zu Verspätungen und Flugausfällen
Sportler des Jahres 2022 bei der
zdf-gala wurden gestern am späten Abend
Sprinterin China lückencamper und zehn
Kämpfer Niklas Kaul ausgezeichnet beide
hatten bei den European Championships in
München EM-Titel gewonnen
Mannschaft des Jahres wurde Eintracht
Frankfurt stellvertretend Namen
Präsident Fischer den Preis entgegen
eins war die Völklinger Hütte ja eine
Herzkammer der Industrialisierung und
wurde dann als weltweit einzig
vollständig erhaltenes Eisenwerk zum
Weltkulturerbe ein Denkmal das über mehr
sein will als nur ein stillgelegter
Erinnerungsort und so gibt es dort
höchst lebendige Ausstellungen aktuell
für die Installation von Julian rosefeld
euphoria heißt eine der Arbeiten die er
dort auf seiner Werkschau zeigt
euphorisch wird einem bei der
Betrachtung zu eigentlich nicht zumute
aber unsere Autorin Verena Garrett hat
Julian rosefeld erklärt warum er
trotzdem ein Optimist ist
ein singender Tiger als Sinnbild des
Kapitalismus streift durch einen leeren
Supermarkt
Obdachlose philosophieren über
Wirtschaftstheorien ihnen wurden Text
Zitate großer Denker in den Mund gelegt
Banker im Rausch der Tanz um das goldene
Kalb alles dreht sich nur noch um Macht
und Geld
die aufwendige 360 Grad Installation
euphoria unterlegt mit einer
kursa ist das jüngste Werk Julian
rosefelds einen Streifzug durch die
Geschichte der menschlichen Gier sagt
der Künstler wo vorher wieder Titel
schon andeutet weist hin auf die
euphorisierende
Grund Energie im Kapitalismus und geht
der Frage nach warum der Kapitalismus
nach wie vor
mehr oder weniger unangefochten das
System ist in dem wir agieren und leben
und warum es
auch weiterhin auch von uns Kritikern
das Kapitalismus akzeptiert wird
die Ausstellung sieben
filminstallationen rosefelds schaffen
der letzten 20 Jahre auf 6000
Quadratmetern Industriekultur in der
Völklinger Hütte die Arbeiten spiegeln
die Zeit von den goldenen Zwanzigern
über die Gegenwart bis in die Zukunft
wieder und die Hütte ist nicht nur
Austragungsort sondern wird Teil der
Ausstellung
das sind alles Themen die hier für
diesen Ort von ganz zentraler Bedeutung
sind wir haben hier auch die
umweltverschmutzt es geht darum wie wird
das weitergehen mit unserer Welt und wie
Julian rosefeld das macht mit Humor mit
bildwitz mit einem ungeheuren
anspielungsreichtum diese Themen alle
die ja sehr schwer sind sehr ernst in
einer doch ungeheurigen Dynamik und
Kraft rüberzubringen das ist das was
mich persönlich fasziniert
wirtschaftliche Unsicherheit Spaltung
der Gesellschaft Juliane rosefels
Arbeiten zeigen die Probleme unserer
Zeit
und wir sind eigentlich wirklich in der
vergleichbaren Situation wie in den 20er
Jahren des letzten Jahrhunderts das hat
er beim Republik und das versucht die
Ausstellung auch zu zeigen über
historische Bezüge und eben auch darauf
hinzuweisen
vielleicht ist der Mensch nicht
besonders gut darin ist aus der
Geschichte zu lernen
ein Blick in Zeitlupe in einer
unbestimmte Zukunft verfallende
Strukturen verlassene Landstriche
pessimistische Visionen nicht unbedingt
ich bin grenzenlose Optimist und ich
denke das spürt man auch in den Arbeiten
die haben natürlich
beschäftigen sie sich mit Endzeit
Szenarien aber es gibt immer etwas was
vielleicht mehr ausdrückt als nur eine
Hoffnungsschimmer oder so oder immer
auch was was heilendes hatte was
optimistisches hat was was extreme
Lebens hat die große workshow von Julian
rosefeld sie vermittelt eine Mischung
zwischen Wehmut und Aufbruch und sie ist
aktueller denn je
[Musik]
das war es von uns gleich geht's mit der
Serie Hamilton weiter und um 23 Uhr
meldet sich dann Gundula Gause mit
unserem heute-update wir melden uns
morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten Abend in diesem Dezember waren die
hoch sehr meist sehr stark und jetzt
aber hat so ein Hoch einen richtigen
Gegenspieler nämlich dieses Tief
Franziska heute gab es ja diesen
gefährlichen Glatteis Regen und jetzt
kommt weiterhin milde Luft aus Südwesten
heran und es kommt auch noch mehr Regen
hinterher damit ist die Frost Luft aber
aus Deutschland fast überall weggeräumt
zu erwarten uns Tiefsttemperaturen hier
im Westen von sieben bis zwei Grad und
der Frost beschränkt sich doch
eigentlich auf Bayern bei -3 bis -6 Grad
dort bleibt es heute Nacht meist trocken
Nordwesten aber fällt Regen und es kann
auch noch gefährlich glatt sein auf den
Straßen die Richtung Vorpommern und vor
allen Dingen auch in den Mittelgebirgen
also in den höheren Lagen an dieser
Wetter zwei Teilung ändert sich auch
morgen über Tag wenig im Nordwesten ist
es bedeckt es fällt häufig Regen bei
Südwestwind Richtung Südosten ganz meist
trocken ab und zu sehen Sie die Sonne
auch mal länger wie am Alpenrand in
Niederbayern hält sich morgen noch ein
bisschen was von der Kälte da bleibt es
beim Dauerfrost sonst wird es zum Teil
vor frühlingshaft mild mit bis zu 12
Grad am oberhalb und auch in den
nächsten Tagen geht es doch sehr
wechselhaft und regnerisch weiter am
Freitag droht dann Sturm bei bis zu 16
Grad am längsten hält sich die Kälte ja
hier in Niederbayern und hier am Trend
für Passau sehen Sie das über die
Weihnachtstage ist allerdings auch dort
deutlich milder wird und erst wieder
nach Weihnachten sinken die Temperaturen
in Richtung Gefrierpunkt und nachts auch
da runter guten Abend